근본주의의 개념은 본질적으로
양자역학에서 측정의 개념과 연결되어 있어
양자역학이 발전하기 이전에는
과학자들 사이에 일반적으로 알려진 사실이 있었는데
어떤 계가 있을 때
그 계가 특정 상태에 있으면
측정을 수행하면
아주 명확한 결과를 얻을 수 있다는 거야
양자역학에서는 더 이상 그렇지 않아, 계가
완벽하게 잘 정의된 상태에 있을 수 있는데
그럼에도 불구하고 특정
측정을 하면 무작위 결과가 나올 수 있어
그 개념을 잘 설명하기 위해서
중첩의 개념을 가져와야 해
중첩은 여기에만 있는 개념이 아니야
여러 상태의 선형 결합이
동시에 나타나는 것에 기반을 두고 있어
동시에 존재하는 거야, 그리고
예를 들면 여러 다른 주파수를 가진
라디오파처럼 생각할 수 있어, 거기엔
인간적인 제약이 없어
중첩에 양자적 특성을 부여하는 건 바로
계를 측정한다는 사실이야
예시를 들어서 설명할게
화살표들로 이루어진 계가 있다고 상상해봐
그 계를 준비해서
모든 화살표가 왼쪽을 가리키게 해
그러고 나서
위아래 중 어디를 가리키냐고 질문을 해
그러면 화살표가 왼쪽을 가리키기 때문에
표현하자면
위와 아래의 중첩으로
설명할 수 있어서
결과의 50퍼센트는 위
50퍼센트는 아래가 나와, 위냐고 물어보면
그 계에서 그 결과를 얻게 돼
그리고 나서 다른 상태로 준비할 수 있는데
절반은 위를 가리키고
절반은 아래를 가리키는 상태로
같은 질문을 하면
같은 결과가 나와
이 두 계는 아주 달라
그런데 지금 이 정보를 얻었어
꽤 오랫동안
그럼 차이가 뭔지 어떻게 알 수 있을까
두 계는 아주 달라
첫 번째 경우에는 계를
순수한 상태로 준비했기 때문에
계에 결정론적인 답을 줄 수 있는
무작위가 아닌 질문을 할 수 있어, 그 질문은 왼쪽이냐 오른쪽이냐야
100퍼센트 왼쪽이라고 알려줄 거야
두 번째 경우에는 물어볼 질문이 없어
100퍼센트 결과를 줄 수 있는 질문이 없어, 왜냐하면
혼합 상태이기 때문이야
그러니까 왼쪽이냐 오른쪽이냐 물어보면
무작위가 나올 거야, 절반은 위이고
절반은 아래니까, 위아래를 물어봐도
마찬가지야, 50퍼센트가 나올 거야
이게 무작위와 어떤 관련이 있냐면
동전 던지기랑
비슷하다고 생각할 수 있어, 앞면 뒷면이 나오니까
하지만 동전 던지기랑 완전히 같지는 않아
왜냐하면 동전을 던질 때
결과를 모르는 유일한 이유는
모르기 때문이야
동전을 던진 에너지, 각도, 순간,
주변 환경 조건
기타 등등을 몰라서야, 그래서 그런
변수들을 다 알면 앞면 뒷면을 예측할 수 있어
관찰자에게 숨겨진 변수들이야
오랫동안 과학자들은 양자역학에도
비슷한 변수들이 있다고 생각했어
그게 무작위로 나타나는 거라고
그건
60년대 John Bell의 seminal한 연구가 나오기 전까지였어
실제로 그렇지 않다는 게 증명됐어
지금은 모든 물리학자들이
숨겨진 변수가 없다는 걸 인정해
양자역학과 양립할 수 있는 숨겨진 변수 이론은 없어
그러니까 계를 측정할 때
자연이 드러내는 건 진짜로
아무리 생각해도 나는
그게 정말 놀랍다고 생각해